today i'd like to talk a bit more about
my book
and if you've got the book then it will
benefit
you to
study the pages
i'm going to go through the the whole
technical section
stage by stage i'm just going to jump
um
it's strange what we all think about
isn't it
this morning
i couldn't sleep so good
i woke up at four
and i lay there
quite happy i was thinking about aikido
so that was that's always a good
sign for me
and um i thought about tension aggie so
i'd like to explain to you
what saito sensei said to me what they
said on the seminar to people about
tension aggie and how it's so
misinterpreted
if you've got my book it's on page 140
and
i'll just
show you the
the pages here
this is the very important one and this
what we'll be talking about
um on this
on this page
with photo two
okay well they're all important and
we'll go through these stages
tension again
is
uh
i only know of two
some people try and say tension egg is
dancing from all sorts of ways you can
do it from static basic or you can do it
from kina nagari you know
so you offer your partner
two hands if they come
you'll
take one down
and one
up and as they come in it's a little bit
like a fish being caught by a net
you don't have to do any more than just
reshape it so you're offering them your
hands
always hit width apart don't offer them
wide
keep don't offer them too close you need
to be comfortable
hit with the pump this is a natural look
natural i just bring my arms up i don't
have to sort of shape them in it
not sure
okay
so
they they
they grab
the rest
you energize your
you energize your hands
as they come in
you
turn your i'm because i'm going this way
i'm going to turn my left foot because
my left foot is forward
you don't even see the feet it's a nine
point it's the hands
this one is gonna do this
this one's gonna do that
this
this is the forward
this is from key on
so they hold it here from key on
this thumb is in line with this
center and it's at my navel height my
navel height
okay so they grab from static basic
solid they solidly
grip your wrists
you
start to turn like this
it's a heaven and earth throw it's
called heaven and earth
now i used to think when i was a q grade
i used to think that um
it means that this hand keeps the earth
and this hand goes to heaven
and perhaps you could think of it like
that okay
but what i now know in myself is what
happens is when i finally get to the
point
as i'm about to throw
i lock their body
and as i lock their body to me
it's heaven and earth being locked
together
locked together
and the lock is between these two hands
between
this part
and this part
notice this even though it's changed
it's still in front of my center
the person like you the camera is in
front of me
i have to go offline and this is where
the partner practice with the ken really
helps or
kai suzuki
actually ski whatever you want to know
as
um
so it's going offline
so they grab very solid
you can't move this arm out
that's why you don't want it
out in the beginning
because you're now it's not in front of
your center anymore
so by doing this it's still not in front
of my center but as i do the shaping
with the hand
it the thumb now lines up
so as i move out offline
the hands moves
slight it moves past that pelvis
in front so it's
basically it's in front of their groin
level
it passes past that pelvis and it tucks
behind their
their right buttock
since i've gone to the left
this nail this thumb is behind their
right buttock
my fingers should be almost
in the crease
here of their two buttocks
and just under
this part of the buttock
so i have a place
that basic means precision precision
done in the most difficult format
so
this hand
as you'll see if you've got the book
it's going to go
around them and in
my body is keeping
in line as i do this
my body is keeping in line with my arm
my arms not moving around
okay i'm not moving this around and then
bring it bringing them back together if
i do that i will need strength because
i need to be
they're holding you strong remember so
they're not going to be allowing you to
use
their body like bellows
so this comes here this one goes behind
their buttock
this one comes up their body
up their center line
and it's going to go over here
it's going to come up and
make a track over as close as you can to
their side of their neck because that's
the quickest point of entry for you
so
here
and again you'll see the arm doesn't
wave around a lot
it comes here
there's a very faster rim and aggie from
sherman ooch where you knock their
showmans slightly offline you go past
their neck
and you
aim like this and you do a lemonade
so it's got very similar characteristic
to that
tension aggie
as i've said kind of the gallery
you bring them round and the same thing
you see the hands doing the same thing
their body has got momentum as it comes
towards you
you so
allow them this feeling of please go
past while you're getting out of the way
but you lock them up
and about there
you bring the heaven and earth together
so they're locked
this hand going around the back of their
butter and then
into the middle of their the crease of
their two buttocks this one comes
by the neck
and you look and your whole body becomes
like an iron link
the whole thing is like an iron link
how will you know if you got it right
it'll take you many many years
many years
i'm not going to kid you
it
it's a very difficult technique but if
you find the heaven and earth concept
you don't need strength you need
fluidity
and then mass
fluidity and then math so you're
it's difficult to say you shouldn't be
deterred
but that could mean
you have to be stubborn
so in a way you might have to be
stubborn to keep your focus and your
mind
on the price
so
okay link the two together the two
together
what that does
when correct
you can't really see this
very well
but on this one this is
his back foot
i'm gonna bring that
this those are down in the book this is
his back foot and he's up on his
his whole body feels like he's up on
tiptoes
you might be able to just see it
all right
the the linking
the linking
of this this
and
this
with this link together
takes him up in his feeling here
and that brings his body in a link and
he can't escape now
this arm is straight but it's locked
because aikido is about locked joints
isn't it
we lock we lock joints as well in
aikido and perhaps that's that come from
the dietary days
the next part what is a very big
misconception is
people
call it
many teachers who demonstrate this you
see them do this and they throw their
rookies and ukis do a either backward
roll or forward roll out of it
and saito sensei said this is not
tension again tension aggie
and this
you may not agree with but i need to
pass me on what he told me
um tension aggie when done correctly
you just dip
you just they're they're locked okay
they're up on their toes their heads
bend bend back they're up on their toes
they've got no chance of regaining their
their balance
and you've got control of the technique
you then
and i'm going to use these quite crude
words you just slammed them into the mat
or if it was in the street you'd slam
them into the street the road
okay
it's not aggressive it's the technique
there is no ukemi out of a true tension
aggie
you lock their body from with the heaven
and earth
and you lock heaven and earth together
and they're locked and
then by this
this throw you've locked them then you
just tip the pelvis the same as you
learn about
tipping when you cut and just heat with
the suburi
i hate this this tip when you learn
about the tip that's what you do is a
very small tip because it's quite close
quarters you've got them here you've got
them linked and you just
and it
and it takes them up from their toes
slams them into the mouth
time and time again
i hear on youtube
saying she's saying
attention
and what they're really doing
and i was told this it's not me made it
up
this is cocunagi
it's breaththro
it looks exactly the same but they do
not lock the body
they just take the person
up
and throw them they're throwing them
this way
they're throwing them this way not
that way
not that way
okay
that's the difference between coconutty
what is a breath throw and tension aggie
what is a heaven on earth
with no get out there is no ukemi
if you do have ever done judo
they will teach you how to slap the mat
you just fall down
on your side or your back and you slap
the mat and the slapping
is what takes the
the power out
so as you
you throw them of course
they're going to release
when you when you release them really
they release so they've got the arm and
they do they can do judo
slam
into the tatami
okay any questions always ask them
that's what i'm here for
the advantage of telling you this is i
followed cytoscnc as i've said before
for 19 years around the world twice a
year
i didn't realize at the time how much he
was giving us
he was giving words that westerners need
to hear
in japan what i'm
i'm glad i didn't spend a long time
personally anyone because
when i went to um i realized he just
demonstrates he says very little when i
ask the question why sense he's not
explaining everything he's in a bad mood
i was told by another westerner who'd
been there many years
you're in japan now the tradition is
they show you coffee
and you just do this year in year out
so you don't
get what the western mind needs you
don't get feedback you don't get
information
so that's why i try to give you as much
information as it can and that way you
won't be disillusioned
when you can't do it
but there's no quick fix tension aggie
not many people do because they don't
get a buzz out of it but it's a
wonderful technique and when you do lock
them up with the heaven and earth you
won't need to
talk to me or anybody about it you'll
know that you're in a very special place
between you and your okay
and
they
wonder how you got into that locked
position
and
be careful that you don't be careful
when you're in there you don't over
stretch this way you've got to enter
deeply so it has some remy to it a remy
means to enter deeply to the rear
so tension aggie you need to go around
them and to deeply to their rear
you can see from the side up their head
needs to be here
and up they need to be up
and the up is these final turning of the
hands that's what gets them up
up you don't go up i'm just showing you
up
hope it helps and
good luck in your journey thank you for
your time